spread it is spread open it's right
openness swear to God your best friends
[Applause]
[Laughter]
why don't ever touch my cameras again
that thing stinks
this is porn yeah it is
it is censored it's like Japanese porn
it's tasteful this is this is a
nightmare image man it's just these legs
up in the in the whatever one light is
just horrifying bro that one Spotlight
we pointed it directly at my ass I can't
I can't tell if this is
um like you're on your back or you're on
your stomach oh I'm on my back now I
know you're on your back but it just
this looks like
[Laughter]
one million dollars I feel like it's too
thick
oh ew not not like it was going in me
too thick the glumping was too thin I'm
saying ew because dude you you pay
attention to these last two lines yeah I
don't want to think about you in this
way he's just like it's pretty
it's pretty thick
okay we waited too long we waited too
long waited too long first if you don't
marry this girl we hit it off we hit it
off dude this is like before after
before before we went to the bar we had
a couple drinks I mean if you're like
meeting somebody on these circumstances
like it's like you get like well we've
never done it
you're pretty comfortable pretty quick
though oh okay
but then after
it was it weird no no it was even better
there's no words keep watching this
footage
well yeah dude he's six three
hold on you haven't wait for the other
angle hold on she's like I'm spread I'm
spread
I don't want to joke about this he knows
this person wrong
finish mean he's
mean all right I feel like it's got to
be ready by now stop looking down I
already saw your butthole yeah you
stopped being shot okay he's trying to
remember all right I'm gonna spread it
more open and then we'll try to keep as
much on my butthole as we can we'll do
fail though we can't all this trouble
why did it do three times yeah dude you
know how hard it is to keep that rubber
like that liquidity
no idea yeah no I don't want to Discount
your experience because let me be clear
all right appreciate the [__] out of
Alex
if I can let me just say this when we
when we receive those molds I talked
with them and he goes I'll [__] do it
I said will you actually
he goes yeah I'm like dude
and what I wanted to do this is this is
even better but what I wanted to do was
just put some on the table really have
one and just try to trick you
have like you're like oh I'm like you
just say my producer's [__] well
that's the [__] they don't that
company doesn't make chocolate out of
your molds they just give you like a
bronze paper out of your butthole they
don't make like
your butthole into a chocolate I was
ready to eat you up man I know I was
ready I was ready to have you
oh that makes sure
all right well it falls down you gotta
keep pacing it on my ass
okay that's fine I'm push
ing it
I will even more this just feels like
porn it does
like to anyone listening they're like
this is just you guys are just on
PornHub they're like attending like
they're like I'm pushing it they're like
nice bit nice bit yeah yeah yeah it's
not nice to steal people's content
who actually made this
films too
she just didn't want to be like her face
showing her name
Champion dude
if you I'm serious if you don't marry
this girl I mean we're gonna we're going
another date yeah you're an idiot if you
don't how do you talk this though yeah
and she was like we can keep that on the
back burner
I'm sorry
you can tell me not not true not true
this is kind of beautiful Alex is just
getting into it he's like you can tell
me anything it's kind of beautiful you
can tell me anything I'm listen well I'm
an open book right now
oh man give it 10 more minutes of this
there's a childhood trauma yeah so then
I saw my uncle
and he was reverse
than anybody in my entire life
killer butthole
you're the only person that's seen my
butthole lose up close
the killer like why like it's not shaved
as a normal bottle I mean dude you're
getting burned down
I know she's roasting man she's holding
your thighs she's like she's gripping
them
[Laughter]
you don't think it works yeah no oh no
it didn't work so we had to do it a
fourth time so if we want to play that
clip real quick oh my God
[Laughter]
the ad said you need an open-minded
friend yeah yeah and he was open-minded
and yeah
open legged front yeah
it looks like a moon rock
oh
don't be [__] rude that looks like a
fossil imagine funny imagine like an
archaeologist finding it
what is it I think it's some sort of
crustacean
you got to bring It full circle and mold
hers that's what I wanted to do and do
his and hers yeah so
side blacks yeah and then when you guys
get married you should like yeah
you know I don't know send the paper
weights as invites yeah exactly yes yes
God damn dude the one thing I will say
is there wasn't enough angles in the
video
I wanted to set one up like a GoPro I
was gonna set up one between her legs so
you can see directly into my anus but I
thought that would just be completely
blurred out so I didn't I don't think it
was worth it all right man appreciate
you guys thank you dude everyone Make
some noise for Alex
[Applause]
what an episode I'm like exhausted yeah
you have a full bonus to do what we got
a Bonus to get to we should just mold
Alex's [__] for the bonus live yeah
that'll be our next moment House show
yeah oh mold a fan
[Laughter]
we're choosing one lucky guy to get his
anus molded on live TV
[Laughter]
being tall [__] rules probably crazy
probably probably
we'll never know yeah
oh yeah
oh
stop doing that
yes
hold on a video of Alex moaning